where P is the principle amount borrowed
a is a periodic amortization payment R
is a periodic interest rate divided by
100 I think it's a little early for this
oh yeah this is maybe more bedtime
reading early in today early in her life
I just wanted to have a good head start
they say that kids who learn about money
early on develop better financial habits
as adults she's three months old you
mean one fiscal quarter all I'm putting
her down for a nap a recent study found
that 44% of Americans consider personal
finance to be the most difficult topic
to discuss with others more so than
politics religion or death
maybe that's why most parents are more
comfortable discussing birds and bees
with in terms and fees see what I did
there and when parents do discuss
finances with their children they tend
to limit it to simple ideas like saving
spending and earning researchers at
North Carolina University found that
children is sensed that certain topics
were off-limits including family
finances parental income investments in
debt if investments in debt were
discussed at all they were far more
likely to be discussed with boys and not
girls and most children had no idea why
their parents were secretive about these
things the truth is that money
management is one of the most useful
skills for getting by in our modern
world yet one that many Americans are
never formally taught not in school or
from their parents
so who does teach today's children about
money advertisers who believe it or not
might not have your family's best
interest at heart unfortunately there
are a lot of predatory organizations out
there that make big profits from other
people's poor financial decisions don't
get us wrong making mistakes is an
invaluable part of the learning process
but when you're young mistakes don't
hurt that much if you're a lemonade
stand doesn't sell enough units to cover
overhead well you're out a couple bucks
but you've learned
important lesson on managing cash flow
that same lesson in your 20s will cost
you a heck of a lot more than a couple
bucks in fact it could say you want a
slippery slope to lifelong debt
a study by Edutopia found that kids who
are taught financial literacy tended to
have less debt and a higher net worth as
adults now we're not suggesting you run
off and discuss correlation coefficients
with your first grader as your child's
brain develops certain topics will be
more age-appropriate than others when a
child is between four and six they're
ready to be introduced to the basic
concepts of money money buys things it
can be earned and some people have more
than others games that use coins or
paper currency can be a great way to
make money seem less abstract and more
concrete at around six to nine years old
children can begin interacting with
money in the real world you might decide
to give them a regular allowance or pay
them for doing extra chores or getting
good grades this is also a good time to
encourage giving help them pick a
charity that they like and take them to
make a donation in person to see the
human impact of their gift between 10
and 15 kids become able to absorb more
advanced financial concepts like
borrowing
and investing if your child has their
heart set on a big purchase you might
consider loaning them the money you
could even charge them interest and put
it in their college fund better they
learn the concept from you than from a
credit card company alternatively if
they've managed to save some money help
them research investment options like a
CD savings bond or mutual fund nothing
can get them excited about finances
quite like watching their money grow as
they become a teenager you should begin
to reveal greater details of your own
financial habits and situation I know it
seems weird but Frank discussions about
your salary mortgage taxes even debt
could give them a huge leg up as adults
if there's something in your finances
your
well there's nothing more natural than
kids learning from their parents
mistakes it's also the best way to
familiarize them with the logistics of
money management ATMs digital banking
accounting apps show them how you
actually keep track of your balances and
pay your bills
most people have to figure that stuff
out all on their own but it doesn't have
to be that way remember you don't have
to be a perfect teacher many parents
don't bring up the topic of money
because they don't want to say the wrong
thing but any kind of introduction is
better than none at all one way or
another your kids won't learn these
lessons
wouldn't you rather it come from someone
who genuinely wants what's best for them
and that's our two cents
you
[Music]